reports a warning there's some flash
photography here it was at Demi Lovato's
home in the Hollywood Hills that
paramedics reportedly found her
unconscious and suffering the effects of
an overdose she was taken to hospital
where she is now said to be recovering
the stars never hidden her struggles
with depression and substance abuse I
had to come to a point where I realized
that I had a serious problem and and
admitting it was the hardest part for a
long time they were struggles she
appeared to be winning undergoing
rehabbing speaking out about the need
for more support for others was the
release of a new song sober last month
that hinted she'd relapsed after six
years of sobriety
[Music]
please forgive me for the drink spilled
on the floor his latest news prompted
the spread of the hashtag pray for Demi
across Twitter celebrity friends
including ariana grande tweeting their
love along with Ke$ha thinking of you
your family and fans and friends she
wrote praying for you TV host Ellen
DeGeneres tweeted I love Demi Lovato so
much it breaks my heart that she's going
through this she is a light in this
world and I'm sending my love to her and
her family and Lily Allen called Lovato
a beautiful spirit I hope she's okay she
wrote and that she makes a full recovery
soon as Demi Lovato grew from child
actor to best-selling pop star she
talked of using her fame to help others
spokesman for her says she is awake and
with her family and grateful for all the
support this experience a reminder that
for so many who face struggles like hers
that fight is an ongoing one Greg Milam
Sky News Los Angeles
[Applause]